TYRANNY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, UNLESS SOMEONE
STOPS IT VERY SOON, IT IS
COMING.
ERIC SCHMITT IS ONE OF THE FEW
THAT IS TAKING ACTIVE STEPS TO
STOP IT.
HE'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
STATE OF MISSOURI.
MISSOURI IS LEADING A COALITION
OF STATES THAT JUST OBTAINED AN
INJUNCTION AGAINST JOE BIDEN'S
VACCINE MANDATE FOR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
I APPRECIATE THIS SINCE YOU'RE
ONE OF SO FEW OFFICE HOLDERS WHO
ARE STANDING UP FOR THE CITIZENS
OF THIS COUNTRY.
TELL US WHERE WE ARE TONIGHT
WITH YOUR EFFORT TO STOP THESE
MANDATES.
>> WELL, LOOK, IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE, YOU HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD HERE.
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN ABOUT FACTS
OR SCIENCE OR DATA.
IT'S ABOUT AGGREGATING POWER AND
CONTROL.
AND THEY WANT TO EXERCISE IT.
IF THE LEFT HAD IT THEIR WAY,
YOU'D HAVE FAUCI IN HIS BLACK
TURTLE NECK IN HIS TWEED JACKET
DICTATING HOW WE LIVE OUR LIVES.
THIS IS STILL AMERICA.
WE HAVE TO PUSH BACK.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, TUCKER,
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS, BUT I
DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN A
FUTURISTIC DISTOPIAN BIOMEDICAL
SECURITY STATE.
AMERICA IS THE FREEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS.
WE BELIEVE IF YOU DIFFUSE POWER
IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO PURSUE THEIR
DREAMS.
SO THIS WEEK, WE LED A TEN-STATE
COALITION THAT WON AGAINST JOE
BIDEN, AGAINST HIS FEDERAL
VACCINE MANDATE AGAINST
HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
THERE'S NO STATUTORY OR
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY FOR ANY
OF THIS STUFF.
THEY'RE MAKING IT UP SO WE'RE
GOING TO COURT AND WINNING.
BECAUSE, IN MY VIEW, THE FUTURE
OF THIS COUNTRY IS AT STAKE.
WHO WE ARE, WHO WE'VE BEEN, WHAT
KIND OF COUNTRY WE'RE GOING TO
BE.
AND WE HAVE TO FIGHT BACK ON
EVERY FRONT, EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> SO, ARE YOU -- SINCE YOU ARE
AN ATTORNEY, YOU'RE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF A MAJOR AMERICAN
STATE.
I MEAN, HOW DID ROCHELLE
WOLENSKY WHO'S BEEN A
DEMONSTRABLE FAILURE -- MORE
PEOPLE DIED UNDER HER THAN THE
LAST CDC DIRECTOR, SO YOU
FAILED, WHICH IS KIND OF BEYOND
DEBATE.
HOW DID SHE WIND UP WITH INTEL
AGENCY LEVEL SURVEILLANCE POWERS
OVER AMERICAN CITIZENS?
I'M COMPLETELY CONFUSED BY THIS.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, LOOK, I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT THE LEFT IS HELL BENT ON
AUTHORITARIAN-LIKE POWER.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: YEAH.
>> AND THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS OUR
FOUNDERS, LIKE THEY WERE GREAT
STUDENTS OF HUMAN NATURE.
THEY HAVE HAD SEEN, YOU KNOW,
HOW TIERNTS AND DICTATORS AND
THE AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AGGREGATED
POWERS. SO THEIR SYSTEM WAS
SEPARATION OF POWER, CHECKS AND
BALANCES, FEDERALISM.
YOU DIFFUSE THIS POWER SO
INDIVIDUALS CAN HAVE RIGHTS,
PURSUE DREAMS AND HAPPINESS.
THAT'S NOT THE LEFT'S VISION OF
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
THEY BELIEVE IN COMMAND AND
CONTROL.
SO WE'RE NOT HAVING DEBATES
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S THE TAX
RATE?
OR THESE KIND OF TRADITIONAL
POLITICAL DEBATES.
WE'RE HAVING A BIG DEBATE HERE,
TUCKER, ABOUT WHO WE ARE, WHAT
THIS COUNTRY IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE, A GENERATION FROM NOW.
AND RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE YOU
PLAYED THE CLIP FROM AUSTRALIA,
LOOK, PEOPLE ARE BEING ARRESTED
IN PARTS OF THE WORLD RIGHT NOW
FOR NOT WEARING MASKS IN A PARK.
THIS IS CRAZY.
AND THAT'S THE VISION OF AMERICA
FOR THE LEFT. SO, WE HAVE TO
FIGHT BACK.
AND WE HAVE TO BE AS
REPUBLICANS, AS CONSERVATIVES,
WE HAVE TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THIS STUFF AND RECLAIM -- I
MEAN, AMERICANS WANT AMERICA
BACK.
THEY WANT TO GET BACK TO LIVING
THEIR LIVES.
AND THEY CAN DO IT.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO PUT A STOP TO
THIS HYPOCRISY THAT'S HAPPENING
AND THE ELITES RULING FROM ON
HIGH TRYING TO DICTATE WHETHER
WE CAN GO TO WORK THAT DAY, IF
WE CAN GO OUTSIDE OF OUR HOUSE,
WHAT YOU HAVE TO PUT ON YOUR
FACE. THAT'S NOT WHAT AMERICA IS
ABOUT.
THESE LEGAL BATTLES ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, MICHELLE
WOLENSKY HAS NO RIGHT TO SPY ON
YOU AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN AND
WE SHOULD DO WHAT WE